crece la inquietud por peng shuai donde
está la tenista china y en qué
condiciones el último capítulo de la
saga es un correo electrónico que habría
escrito y haya sido publicado por la
prensa nacional dice que no está en
peligro ni desaparecida sino descansando
en casa agradece la preocupación y pide
que no sean publicadas más informaciones
sin ser contrastadas con ella la carta
va dirigida a la asociación de tenis
femenino y su presidente steve simon y
ha respondido que no cree que haya sido
escrito por ella y ha aclarado que sus
temores no han hecho más que aumentar de
la célebre tenista china no se tienen
noticias desde que dos semanas atrás
publicó un post en web o la plataforma
más utilizada en china denunciando que
años atrás habría sido víctima de abusos
sexuales por parte de un ex vice primer
ministro chino con el que después
mantuvo una relación amorosa y que
terminó por decisión de este ese post
fue eliminado desde entonces
organizaciones de derechos humanos y
personalidades del deporte como la
tenista japonesa naomi o xhaka o la ya
retirada chris evert han manifestado su
preocupación por el paradero de penn